acelera la transición energética a toda
costa esta es la principal petición del
último informe de la agencia
internacional de la energía al ritmo
actual los esfuerzos emprendidos por los
estados sólo reducirán las emisiones de
gases de efecto invernadero en un 20%
para 2030
las inversiones actuales en energías
limpias son insuficientes para permitir
una transición energética debemos
triplicar las inversiones en energías
limpias en 10 años de lo contrario
veremos turbulencias en los mercados
energéticos como lo estamos viviendo hoy
markets es bien experiencia today
triplicar las inversiones en 10 años eso
representaría 4 billones de dólares para
la economía global la agencia
internacional aboga por inversiones
masivas y rápidas en opciones eléctricas
fotovoltaicas y eólicas un desafío
colosal en un momento en que los
combustibles fósiles como el petróleo el
gas y el carbón todavía representan el
80 por ciento del consumo final de
energía
cuando observamos los países que se
comprometieron a la neutralización del
carbono de aquí a 2050 aún si se
comprometieron realmente estamos lejos
de alcanzar nuestros objetivos
climáticos que van a cambiar que harán
con la producción de carbono existente
cómo van a transformar el sector
automotriz como planean gestionar las
emisiones del sector industrial de
industrias tantas preguntas dos semanas
antes de la cumbre con 26 en glasgow
durante este encuentro la agencia
internacional de la energía hará un
llamado a los líderes mundiales para que
en esta década haya un despliegue masivo
de energías libres de carbono